construct a line perpendicular to the
given line so if I can pick two
arbitrary points on this line and if I
can make a line that is always
equidistant from those two points then
that line will be perpendicular and
actually it'll be a perpendicular
bisector of the segment formed by those
two points now they don't care that
whether we're bisecting anything but
they do care about it being
perpendicular so let's do this so I'm
going to add I'm gonna draw a circle
with my compass and so let's just pick
that point right over there I could
adjust the radius if I like but I might
as well I'll just leave it right over
there now let me draw another circle and
this time I'm gonna Center it where the
first circle intersects intersects with
my line and then I'm gonna adjust the
radius to overlap with the second with
the second with the first dot I should
say and now where these two circles
intersect those are points that are
equidistant from both of these from both
of these these these centers that I just
constructed so let me draw a line that
connects those two and that line is
going to be perpendicular to our
original to our original line